yo what is up everybody prestige you're
mad Luigi back inside of The Witcher 3
and today I'm gonna be showing you guys
the probably the best Alchemist /
herbalist that I have found inside of
The Witcher 3 with a good amount of time
played and basically being through all
the areas this is the best guy found to
have the most stuff so you're gonna want
to go to the skillet skillet aisles and
getting on the main island the east part
of the island there's a marker and it's
like gwenlyn little blah blah blah or
something i'm i don't know how to
pronounce and it's a little small on my
screen right now and there's going to be
an alchemist right to the north of that
like you can see there's the main part
of the island where you normally ad and
then over here in this in the middle
this forest there's going to be a marker
and maybe i'll have it just kind of go
over here and there's going to be an
alchemist and he's going to be an old
druid and actually to get access to his
um his all about commune stuff you're
gonna have to do a quick side quest for
him it's really not that long you just
got to go gather some stuff you got to
travel a little bit far but it's not too
bad and once you do that
he's gonna open up his inventory for you
and as you can see there's a ton of
stuff mainly you can see all those
crafting recipes and there's a potion of
clearances so every time he restocks
he's gonna have five of those potions of
clearance as i know people have been
asking me about that since some i have
another video about the potion of
clearance and the person i said that has
it doesn't always work for everyone so
this is another place to f5 and as you
can see there's a ton of crafting
recipes for potions and bombs for the
superior which is the final tier of the
potions and the crafting like the bomb
recipes so this guy is going to have the
superior for a lot of things for most of
the stuff that i use a day to day and
he's gonna have a lot of supplies that
you can get for crafting however i must
say this is gonna be pretty expensive
most of them are like 50 bucks or less
but there are some that cost like 500 or
800 and so you get to choose if you want
those I have a lot of money in the game
so I was buying without prejudice just
getting all of them now for this you
will need the enhanced potions and bombs
as and also just the base potions of
moms if you're going to get
these are only upgrades you cannot craft
the predecessor steps off of these and I
know a lot of the Enhanced come from a
dwarf herbalist in in a building in
novigrad so you're going to need that to
get the superior versions to actually
craft them however this is a spot where
has a huge amount of superior potions
and a lot of other stuff so guys that's
going to be basically the video a quick
little location guide for one of the
best alchemists I found hope you guys
enjoyed this if you do make sure you let
me know that you did and so I'll keep
putting more of this kind of stuff up I
know I put up a lot of Witcher 3 content
so check out my channel if you want some
more that that's basically it hope you
guys enjoyed this and I'll see y'all
later peace out see ya